i accidentally became a meme and this is
that story my name is maggie
goldenberger but you may know me as the
irma gerd girl
just as a warning the end of the story
gets pretty weird
so this all started in 1999. i'm in
middle school
playing sports hanging out with my
friends goosebumps had come out a few
years ago
i enjoyed them i wasn't particularly a
fanatic
but my mom remembers it very differently
that i apparently was obsessed with
goosebumps after school
my best best friend kailyn and i would
hang out caitlyn had just gotten that
pull word camera that actually printed
the pictures right there
so we were a little obsessed with that
and would take all sorts of photos all
the time
and we would get dressed up we had a
dress-up box one night we were taking
pictures
and i was trying to look as ridiculous
and as nerdy as possible
we got the goosebumps books out we
grabbed her old backpack from first
grade a vest her mom found a goodwill
took my hair and put him in pigtails i
had a retainer that
i usually wore at night we got it out i
threw it in
and just started making faces so kaylynn
took the picture
we waited five minutes or so for it to
develop
once it was there it was really funny we
thought it was great and
she kept it for years and years and
years fast forward to 2012
i am backpacking in india with my
current girlfriend at the time
and we only have internet access about
once a week we'd go to internet cafe
and i started getting messages from my
mom
wondering why my photo was all over the
internet and that there was some kind of
german writing on my photo and it was
all over and i was like okay mom
i know she does not know how the
internet works so i just ignore her
but then i get a message from a friend
from high school and she says hey just
so you know
this other guy went to high school with
is sharing
that photo of you all over facebook and
i did end up messaging him like hey
i wouldn't mind if you just ask but it's
really strange you're just doing this
without my consent like what's going on
and he's like he had no idea it was me
he
said he found it from a comedy website
so then i realized there's some
legitimacy to what my mom's saying so
now i really want to know what was going
on who would put my photo on the
internet
why is it spreading like wildfire so
when i get back to the us
i was seeing it everywhere every social
media site news outlets
t-shirts with my face on them mugs
countless people were dressed as me for
halloween that year
the guys from nerds made a music video
with the girl from
parramore and i am just watching it
wondering
what on earth is going on so all of this
is happening
i have all these messages asking me what
i'm gonna do about it how i'm gonna make
money off of it
people i need to sue it was uh pretty
overwhelming with all the information
coming in all at once
all the while i'm still trying to figure
out how this
got uploaded because i asked all my
friends no one was copying up to it i
feel like anyone that would do it would
want to take some credit for it
so it wasn't until a vanity fair
article did some serious research and
found out it was from
a photo my friend had uploaded on her
myspace and
it was a public domain this photo bucket
and some stranger a 16 year old canada
just saw it one day thought it was
hilarious and uploaded it to reddit with
the caption
of just a girl in her books and then
another user
put on it gerschfirms my favorite books
like with that
retainer accent and then from there
another user
put the tagline of armorguard and that
is finally when the whole
meme came together i felt mostly okay
with the sharing and the fun of it
spreading some kind of little bit of joy
but
the invasion of privacy and the
non-consensual
telling my face it felt
like a real violation i didn't feel
personally attacked
because i was being a character but
there is still that underlying
feeling like why do adults think it's so
funny to make fun of a young
girl that's excited about books we want
to encourage kids to be reading as many
books as they can get a hold of
one thing that made me really
uncomfortable was i had
a friend of my brothers he wanted to
prove that i was the girl in the meme
so he started revealing personal details
about my life to
an internet community and sharing a
photo of me in a bikini
so i was out at the time but my
girlfriend was not she had a very
conservative family and wasn't
necessarily out to most of them
and so what he was doing to prove it was
me like basically outing her
and outing our relationship he just
opened me up to
that whole community of trolls and the
total violation privacy
okay so this is the weird part so
because i'm a meme i would get
different invites to do appearances and
things like that that i
kind of grazed over and then one came my
way that asked if i wanted to attend
a meme themed jungle furry party in the
bay area i
sent a screenshot to a couple of my
friends and i said hey
the offers keep rolling in everyone
thought it was pretty funny
but one of my friends uh that was in
santa jose she was like oh my gosh
we have to go so we drive to san
francisco
and we come up to this beautiful house
on top of this hill
and something about it just feels a
little spooky to me but we just go with
it
so we go into the house and we meet this
chef and he's telling us we're about to
have a six-course meal
and it's gonna be infused with something
that i can't say in this video
and as i sit down i realize across from
me
is the double rainbow guy and then we
proceed to have the best meal of my life
so during dinner people were wearing
their ears as their designated
characters
but it was after the meal when things
got really furry so we're having drinks
after dinner and more and more people
are showing up
and they're full fur and i'm talking to
double rainbow guy
and he's one of the sweetest people i've
ever met he's just like he is
like just genuine in his video so all of
a sudden i found
myself alone on a couch and next thing i
know
i have a cat coming up to me and starts
purring and rubbing against my legs
and by cat i mean a human being and a
cat costume
and i'm like oh okay this is part of it
i started cutting
oh okay great and then it just
wouldn't end i didn't have a safe word i
didn't know what to do
and i look over and my friend is just on
top of this wolf
and whatever was in the dinner is
starting to kick in
and i i i know i need to get out of
there
so i get up i can't find my friend all
of a sudden i feel his hand on my
back and i turn around and it's her and
she also
needs to go immediately at that moment
nothing sinister happened we just had
enough and had to go
so we left and we had no regrets i had
conversations with some of the most
interesting
and nicest people i've ever met and they
were so warm and welcoming
all in all i have no regrets about the
meme to all the little kids out there
who love to read keep it going reading
is cool
and do not let the internet tell you
[Music]
otherwise
[Music]
you